ah true news is gonna be very different
this week now article 13 has passed
no more clips just gonna be us acting
out what happened blow-by-blow boring
moment by boring muscles up mean we've
got a reluctance to reenact to a well a
drift poor fight that's right LBJ call
ready and
Oh Sam and then ah then go snuggling me
on cranium don't forget to go and buy
the merch in the store hit the link in
the description right there we need Khan
to lick your ass like one of his
entourage yeah sure okay sure well yeah
[Music]
for a first time in what feels like
forever nor pedophiles all terrorists
Colin true news brilliant well done
everyone
how [__] [__] up this week whatever
you did it wasn't as bad as what has
been going on Lindy Conor McGregor we'll
start with him I do like talking about
fights when it comes to fight as
unfortunately with him never really
seems to be about that these days now
some products proper thirteen ski you
know me I've been a [__] fan of this
constant long still the same old G not
of beef I've been a father McGregor it's
getting harder to like this guy he's
retired from fighting on Twitter not not
a real retirement [__] retirement
basically he's in negotiations with the
UFC they're playing a bit of hardball
they tried to put him for some reason
and I don't get there now I yeah as a
co-main event instead of a main event
he's the biggest selling fighter in
pay-per-view history on the UFC anyway
just give him his own court anyway on
the same day it was finally revealed
that he's under investigation in Ireland
for sexual assault allegations it's not
good
as a father McGregor it's not the
[__] headline you're hoping for now
don't get me wrong he might be
completely innocent and we hope he is
innocent we hope nothing happened yeah
but another headline revolve in Conor
McGregor that doesn't have anything to
do with an actual fight promote your
whiskey will buy the whiskey promote you
cruelly I'll buy you our support here's
a fun book fight me or or retire like an
actual retirement out a black outline
retire on the same day the sexual
assault allegations come out he pours on
Instagram him in his missus cheersing
pina coladas I'm not seeing he did it
however it's not the [__] Porsche you
put out on the day that comes out is it
he got caught in the rain like at this
point he's almost becoming the Kim
Kardashian of fighting weight it's like
it's not even about what you used to be
famous for anymore you're just famous
I'm just sick of the [__] [__] do
you think there's a taller theory that
sometimes careers can overextend
themselves too much is taken on that's
what Conor McGregor's done when you're a
multi multi-millionaire and your
photograph coming out of certain [__]
holes and Dublin then that's definitely
gonna happen sooner than later Jeremy
and sort your [__] out solemn anyway
yeah moving on to the next
Joella
holiday what do you normally do on your
holiday that's right visit your friends
[Music]
welcome boys and girls to Jay Paul
versus Joe Weller
oh nice Combofiend donkey hey and the
Bell was gone well I get back up there
yeah he's had them not lose wind knocked
out of him but he ended being all right
you go on for tomorrow he was badly
wounded though it's that it's the liver
shot isn't it basically it wasn't it
wasn't it was in the what I'd called
breadbasket so just right in the wind
versus yeah if he's got a load an
angstrom yeah all right so basically
what happened
Joella despite not training boxing for
probably a year now
yeah I just thought [__] it I'll get in
with him which I rate by the way the
lads got [__] bottle no-one can see
he hasn't got bottle but Jay Paul
regularly is trained by a coach that you
see Milton supreme there was a guy came
the podcast this guy's trained world
champion so jig holds getting regularly
trained by him well a is just gone for a
little scrub in the park sauce well as
wearing trainers we got Jay King exactly
it sinks exactly so you can see one of
them to take the form or Suzie what Jake
also showed unfortunately is that he can
be a bit of a knob I'm a bit biased or
was giorgos our guidebook the treatment
afterwards just annoyed me like this is
supposed to be in good spirits you know
the kids had the bottle to come into
your backyard at least treat him like
he's all your friends exactly yeah you
know faithful a kid you came you got
hurt
forget about it you see this little
[__] prick yeah oh do you not like
him Joe was dropped he wasn't knocked
out though Jimmy I he's perfectly
[__] conscious choice lay on the
floor
Jake is cutting a [__] promoter the
common this is not WEA this is like a
little sparring thing that they did in
the back garden do you think he asked
Joe to do that and Joe sort of played
along a little bit because Joey
Joe has that element of actor I've
textual none of this was [__] acting
listen he said this was not acting I
wasn't paid actually I did take a fall
wasn't paid so no not a literally none
of them give a [__] you
you know what is right
I like his eyebrows though they look
well drawn on one day this guy something
Bad's gonna happen to him whoa and I
really hope not because of you and I
wrote yeah I read all threats when it
does we all saw him see him sort of
respect Yeah right say he falls over in
the street you're gonna be the one going
there he fell over oh he fell I don't
sound like that but yeah well he's
actually quite good you're actually
quite good I respect that
no cool jaws often classy each got up
Fairplay appears it's not the best
freeze frame so immediately after Joe
gets roughed up and probably a bit
discombobulated yeah the cameras start
rolling Jake's buddy start shooting a
music video all about how Jake's gonna
knock your wallet out and interestingly
mm-hmm GJ new admits he can't stand Joe
at this point for all the things I've
gone on as he comes to Jaws defense
[Music]
watching Joe took it so well like a
proper Jen yeah but equally you feel
sorry for him because he's he's kind of
having to be like alright if I get angry
here I'm gonna look like a dick you also
lot like a dick by going along with it
so you're [__] either way really in
his head it doesn't do Joe any favors
we'll say a mugging off Joella in front
of his face
I don't was pointing himself Joe was
pointing at himself like yeah he's gonna
knock me out Joe have some dignity man
Joe has gone away gone on a spiritual
journey and risen above all this YouTube
[__] of clout and all that stuff
yeah doesn't give a [__] I agree with
you but I kind of see where change is
coming from in that they're just mugging
him off you know me it's annoying I can
see both sides yeah so they're mocking
on that one they're both right Joe
doesn't care yeah I like that
yeah but equally we care about how Joe
law and seeing people mug him off
that is annoying why would you be a
backup dancer on a dis truck that's at
you he's mocking you off and you're
mocking yourself Oh have some dignity my
don't let you should never have let this
happen for well this is man this is
actually for for Joe I think that shows
the difference also a mentality between
Joe and JJ I don't know I think there's
a weird relationship between him and joy
and that there's a there's a bit of a
bonding yeah in that when you shared
that moment in the ring together and
also JJ very much helped make Joe's
career seeing Jake in JJ's eyes destroy
credibility destroy what jaws built up
and make him look foolish
JJ feels a bit of ownership over Joe and
like how can you allow how can you allow
him do that and JJ already hating Jake
saying Jake stop rise because of that
who want to [__] him up cause of it on
the plus side we might get JJ versus
Jake that'd be a pretty good fight now
I'm starting to get more into that
George was since retired from Boston I
think that that is a shame because he
kind of started the boxing thing on
YouTube and I do a lot of people are
saying he could fight dead G very
similar in size both coming off a loss
it's not trained in a while yes I'll be
cool if they wanted to do it if they do
need another [__] epic undercard
fight that would be I'll be sick did you
watch the log in flat earth oh yeah
quick assault so if it was a screening
you know how you can go to a screening
in public and afterwards Logan had come
out the way I'd react to this is I would
go you're up on the screen the crowd
really seemed to react nicely to it
anyway see ya I didn't feel I didn't
feel passionate about it I didn't feel
let down by it because I invested
nothing in it he's obviously watched
Shane Dawson and being inspired by that
but also sort of wanted to put a
character across short sure that he can
act sort of thing have a bit of fun with
it I like it when youtubers try to do
something a bit bigger and a bit more I
thought going in there and pretending
that you're part of this whole flower
thing and getting people to believe you
remember Borat and people characters
like that
it's months and months of them living
and breathing this identity you only got
one shot of this now people know that
Logan's gonna try and fool people he's
probably not going to be able to do that
again so I think he should have done
more with it towards the end there was
some funny moments in there
it was quite one I think when his friend
told him it was all a joke that made me
laugh a bit remember dude where's my car
yeah it was a bit like that it was like
alright this is [__] but it is kind
of funny [__] yeah I
this one would be if I could title it
dude where's my content I don't have
you've seen that Instagram thing where
he's talking about Hollywood and should
I conquer Hollywood and he seems a shame
that his sticks up on YouTube he wants
to go big area can I conquer Hollywood
what should I do he's talking to and
keemstar so it took him a tusk a little
bit on it what do you think about the
idea of him trying to be a Hollywood
star I just think my face says it all
you know he's been used to jumping so
he's done vine and then he's done
YouTube and then he tried to do music
and he had some like big videos music
wise but I don't think he's had a
successful music career he wants to do
movies I think that's what he's looking
at and thing and that's why I want to go
but the door is sort of shut in it it's
not it's not something you can just
social media following your way and it
was as much Ian honest I think if Logan
wants to conquer Hollywood he's got a
[__] a lot of work they do Georgia my
is acting on that video it was funny at
times but other times it was very basic
you not I mean it you I yeah I think a
lot of people could do better than that
he needs to you need to work on it and
in time I think that's a fair criticism
if he disagrees Fair Play good luck good
luck cardi B recently admitted to using
sex to drug and Rob men for them
[Music]
lovely lady she is our Pepsi must be
absolutely [__] themselves with all
of the [__] decisions they've made
Michael Jackson how could this possibly
go wrong
cardi B oak that's gone [__] crap if
a man lured a woman to a [__] hotel
room drugged out and robbed her and in
he was a successful rap artist
oh we would be [__] hearing about this
in our big way and he certainly wouldn't
be admitting it she admits it freely
because that's how it is and this is
what I'm talking about the double
standards to which men and women are
trapped the fact that she can freely
admit that no one give a [__] I mean
there's a little bit of a kerfuffle but
a little blog I appreciate she was in a
bad situation and if you cancel every
[__] rap artist who's ever done
anything wrong we'd have no rap artist
left other than Will Smith even then you
know Bill Cosby went to prison for this
by the way like drugging and you know I
mean that sort of [__] I think she
thinks some men won't come forward
because the dynamic is not you using a
prostitute now there's no chain rickshaw
some men but I'd be coming forward there
is a guy on instagram that claims Vic
Hardy be drugged and robbed him after
going to the hotel with him so that he
could allegedly pay her for sex
everyone's just a shameless [__]
with no integrity nowadays just [__]
leave it all right okay cardi B she
drugged me and robbed me um oh I'm her
first victim go to the police don't
don't Instagram you dumb [__] everyone
wants a bit of that clout and all that
[__] on it don't get caught from being a
victim that's the worst kind of I would
know another some girl might look at me
like oh god you be [__] them I want to
[__] them how's that status they robbed
you as well what I'll get onto this a
bit later but I hate the way society is
how little bit of attention is with son
and your [__] soul isn't it
yeah effective having said that it's
time for a quick outbreak now we'll see
in just a few minutes hey Brian you
might think that it's like cybercrime
something happens to other people right
basically you know you we're going to
Starbucks we go in towards in places
there's lots of open public Wi-Fi they
go on well there may be people on that
Wi-Fi and in the public area who looking
steal your details do you want them have
your details Brian hasn't you won
no exactly Brian that's why expressvpn
are here to help don't you yeah Thank
You expressvpn for sponsoring this
week's true new social it secures and
anonymizes your internet browsing
because I mean nobody knows it basically
encrypts the data you know the wording
grow buddy knows it but you've got a
secret browser and use it oh and live
for me is that right that's good it's
not really a browser but you feel
they're gonna have that jingle of food
while turning on expressvpn basically
gives you protection in one click bang
on you're protected I like real
protected for less than seven dollars a
month you can also get the same
protection that we've got from
expressvpn absolutely Brian just go to
expressvpn comm forward slash Georgey
Georgey
you got it enough to shout it I want to
protect my ears to expressvpn do
anything for that flush Georgia it's
national important bits all those raisin
cut with a click-clack Express Phoebus
crushing of life Express BPM or us just
do it get three free months within a
one-year package really it's well worth
it I've used VPNs online and expressvpn
are about to change my life Alex and
Jack had a bit of a fallout I'm sure
that I'm promised you'd leave this
because they're both good guys so for
those who remember jack mate and I'm
Alex we're on the Christmas podcast love
them we did their podcast the happy hour
podcast you did it I did it separately
who wanted to milk this a little bit
bless them yeah happened afterwards
though with Brian yeah that was in the
contract yeah so if you're not gonna pay
me at least milk me yeah and then Brian
Mooar
for 10 minutes that they just wiped him
off into a cup all right the Potter is
on the podcast I wasn't really sure why
at the time that that happened but it
seemed like the right move football for
them or whatever you know good look camp
cast happy hour to the pub they both
shout shout them out yeah I mean this
FET say that when people part ways
sometimes after you parted ways you can
think of other things and because
communication isn't the same as it used
to be people feel hurt Alfie deyes what
sets up a podcast of his own Alex he had
something in his mind that they didn't
have he came prepared put certain things
to them but also he had a bit of an
agenda where he was quite determined it
seemed to come out on top I do
Alex was prepared for what was coming he
seemed to come more for a bit of a
friendly chat last podcast he did before
that was ours yeah he's used to getting
pummeled with vodka I've got a couple of
quotes from different things that you
guys have said and then we can go into
more general the whole quirky blogger
thing is [__] [__]
yes vloggers are [__] yeah and it's
starting to get to point where I really
despised the genre and I can't bear it I
just say that yeah yeah you said that
bro that's a quote I don't think Alfie
was particularly wrong wanting to bring
those things up I just got the vibe that
he didn't let them know before they came
what they were walking into they didn't
exactly ask him before they nailed him
on videos either did they so you sort of
within his rights a little bit Chuck
made a video [__] on a lot of the
points that Alfie made and expose a lot
of holes in Alfie's points in this video
and he is good at it you've gotta give
him credit yes very good I didn't find
I'll be very likable in that podcast
because I felt like he was almost
combating [__] with his own [__]
rather than he wasn't going let's be
honest he didn't come correct he came
along and went I'm gonna make count of
points to all your points and I'm gonna
have them pre-prepared even if my
cutting points aren't exactly true as
long as I make them in your on the spot
and haven't really got an answer
prepared I'm gonna make you look stupid
and that's kind of what he did Alex a
little bit and so in this video Jack
points that out and the problem is him
and Alex haven't spoken in a while and
we Alex wasn't one thrilled thrilled
yeah he rolled is the word he was upset
he's not thrilled he was really upset I
have been personally [__] thrown
under the bus today that's how I feel I
am [__] so angry they are making I'm
shaking I'm so upset with the way that I
have been treated over the last month
and a half by people who won't just
might be friends but even colleagues of
mine people I work with I feel
passionately like I've been stabbed in
the back I think that that was the heat
of the moment yeah that just shows how
upset Alex was ultimately two good guys
communication just needs to be better
but we couldn't do a [__] true news
with ignore two of the biggest [__]
commentary lads who are also army it's
having a bit of a Barney the truest of
all the new it's apparently the good
news is you Jack and Alex
spoken on the phone
right and they've squashed it when great
[__] talkers fall out with each other
it makes for fireworks let's hope we
don't ever fall out yeah cuz you are
[__] that's a that's a but like we're
definitely not least because you're very
good at put downs but you just know too
much I mean in many ways I'm gonna
enable more than anything on you
sometimes when judgmental people fall
into situations where you can be judged
they start to see what it's really like
for the people in their own videos
Laurence McKenna or as we like to call
him on the shore Lisa Simpson Adam 22
you know that guy who does the hip hop
stuff are like yeah yeah he was in the
middle of a live stream oh it went down
this is all real by the way whoa
someone's holding him up trying to get
money out of him
what yeah look at least someone laid the
guy out and I don't know if that gun was
loaded item 22 had a lot of like Duff
stops where people have could like
heavily involved in the rock community
to a point where he's he's there Jimin I
mean so cuz I'd like to do a podcast
with this guy he seems like a cool guy
he's got a pornstar girlfriend like he's
my kind of guy oh yeah get some security
man cuz that's what week I won't be
alive for when I go over to LA I want to
do a podcast was right for those who
remember a video we did recently called
reacting to WorldStarHipHop videos
whatever the [__] it was got on TGT we
react the novice on the main channel you
put that [__] on the main channel yeah
one of the Rattlers that we were have to
skinny from the name just got the dog
[__] Bo go on whoa the guy was asking
for a four door that's that's a photo
yeah he came asking for a fall and then
started doing that yeah but he leaves
them I didn't realize he does some
pretty good to me that's a [__] move
like you know I mean if you wanna fight
a guy you say yeah outside yeah I'm
[__] fight in the middle of he's about
to get his [__] chicken and rice on
and y'all [__] just beating this [__]
he's with he's on a date he's on a date
with the girl what you want to hear
parry sauce with that girl or hold on a
second I'm a famous [__] these
people come on take picture with me call
our three person a soda
recently love island star Mike fala
Citiz
we don't watch that Island but I think
it's important thing to bring up anyway
committed suicide the poor guy and he's
the second person on this Shore to do so
and it is quite important to bring up
because reality TV this machine that
we've become used to where people cut to
pull it from nobodies to somebody's
overnight but
often you're used for your 15 minutes of
fame you promote a few things on your
Instagram and say yeah you get a few
Club appearances you get thrown on a few
TV shows where you're dating something
or other but eventually that passes and
you go about the kind of being who you
were before monie of having the
experience of everyone licking your ass
for that 50 minutes and yeah you can say
that some people aren't ready for that
role of course they're right and I TV
people like that are coming under
scrutiny because they're not giving the
correct aftercare I've read this article
basically the ITV bosses are talking
about how they can't indefinitely as in
forever
give aftercare to someone it's just not
the way it works it's it's not efficient
in that sense so at some point the
person has to go back to independently
dealing with these things and that
becomes a real problem I think there's
two problems male suicide is huge in the
UK right now and that that's something
that needs to be paid attention to by
the government for a start there's
another problem in that if you're a
producer on that show you're almost
looking for victims in my opinion you're
and I don't mean victims of suicide I
mean the victims of a system you're
looking for people to come and be
squeezed and to be thrown away a certain
personality type yes quite
impressionable why quite easily malian
so you're bringing me on another problem
which to me is kind of people who want
to be on these shores there's a hint of
desperation about people who go on
reality TV because if you're succeeding
in your chosen career you're not putting
that on hold and and if you're loving
what you're doing you're not putting
that on hold me like well actually I
just want to go and try and be famous
like the the the idea is to be famous
for the sake of being famous for any
reason it doesn't matter whether people
like you hate you how you're perceived
in the show you're just wanting to be
famous because a lot of people aren't
really happy with their lives beforehand
when they go on this show so therefore
they get under the opinion that if I
could be famous I that would make me
feel better and I'll do things and then
when the system uses Europe spits you
out and [__] you out at some point
you're then but almost less than where
you were before hum because you almost
had that little bit of what it was like
but now you're like oh god now I've had
Fame and no one wants me anymore there's
no longer the excitement of what could
happen it's the excitement of what has
been love Ireland and all these other
shitty TV programmes like
oddish or and all of that to be so
[__] careful with who they pick
because your change in people's lives
and sometimes your changing it in the
worst way you know like they're not
ready for this anyway I just wanted to
cover it because I do think I felt sorry
for the guy but also you know unless
this is highlighted it ain't gonna
change as I think there might be a
podcast in this maybe we should discuss
this at more length UFC fighter Tony
Ferguson one of my favorite fighters you
like him yeah I like to anything I like
his style for those who don't know he's
in conor mcgregor's weight class in he
is one of the very best recently his
wife had a sort of failure restraining
order against him it's just a bit weird
yeah yeah I just want to let you know
he's a professional fighter curtain one
I don't want no cost to get injured and
ah did he hurt you or your children no
no no your can really just random stuff
you know what put holy water on me I
don't know what's going on you can see
she's very scared she mentioned in
putting holy water on her some weird
stuff going on starting to regret saying
he was one of my favorite fighters now
she doesn't strike me as the kind of
woman who is faking this at all she's
not the type of woman who seems to want
to destroy him she just seems scared
Tony has also said disturbing things for
example he called their two-year-old son
Jesus Christ and labeled himself as the
second Jesus Christ she basically seems
she's very scared she just think he
might have a mental illness or whatever
other theories out there in the MMA
accuity that we might be saying one of
the first fighters who is having signs
of CTE where brain trauma there was lot
of people when chris benoit killed his
family when his brain was actually
looking at post death that he had
massive signs of CTE the sport of MMA is
so young we haven't seen the real signs
of someone suffer from that trauma but
this guy takes a lot of punishment I
mean he was interim champion of the
lightweight division before khabib took
the Bell and they've given him some time
off which you'd [__] home that's good
yeah so we hope this time off Tony you
need to focus on your god yeah we hope
the situation improves because [__] I do
feel sorry for his wife in particular
child stars of YouTube hit fantastic
adventures and
abused by adopted mother her children
told the police how they adopted mother
starved beat and pepper sprayed them
when they failed I'm sorry right but the
fact that when they fail to follow
directions for videos imagine me doing
that Waxhaw yeah Stephen me sort of
mentally do it there's I've wanted to do
it as Steven really but anyway moving on
remember Brian when it comes to abuse
cases the kids are probably lying as
we've learned that over the last few if
the Michael Jackson father's I've got
anything just a big laugh she ever
released any records I'm interested I
doubt it or well then she's guilty if I
ever get caught doing a [__] crime of
any kind yeah not abusing shut about any
kind I'm just going to hand off on me
demo tape to the can be like oh yeah get
me off with it you mind releasing this
mixtape is that something you guys could
do cuz this is dinner dinner night Brian
eat a lobster then he goes and gets the
shape I think let's be on the toilet
Maricopa police say Hackney would
routinely pepper spray the children from
head to toe and in their private parts
and authorities say one of the boys
tells them Hackney would pinch his
private parts with her fingernails
making him bleed
sunny well after that the kickoff is
gonna be running like a tight ship from
no one Wow I'll be pinned as neocortex
I'll be pinching your dish yeah good
I'll get into that mate Michelle Hackney
denies using the closet for punishment
and denies the pepper spraying even
though cops found two cans in her room
how's a kid gonna make up a pepper spray
she's going not just like to use on my
dinner the kids not gonna go would now
don't do if I didn't do something right
they probably pepper spray me in the
genitals I've been saying for years that
people putting their kids on YouTube
should be monitored a little bit like
there should be a certain level I don't
know how healthy it is because you're
not portraying reality or relationship
YouTube channels even and this just
proves how [__] fake that reality can
be at the extreme no I it's an extreme
ending yeah I don't think that this
proves that it should be completely done
away with and I'm not even sure I
believe that what [__] me this is fun
I've seen this year the day and I was
reading it right right laughing so hard
right I thought I want you to read this
okay mother of 124 choked to death when
she tried to see how many jaffa cakes
she could fit in her mouth for a party
trick
Bethan Gaskin stopped breathing when the
snacks got lodged in her throat friends
found her slumped in the bathroom at her
home in born Lincolnshire beauty
therapist suffered a heart attack and
died five days later soon she was killed
died today her devastated
adopted mother Michelle 52 warned other
people of the dangers of extreme food
challenges I remember raising my
eyebrows when Bethan started the game
thinking how old are you and telling her
to spit them out she was like a hamster
with her cheeks bulging she danced off
to the toilet to get rid of them and it
was only a while later we realized she
been gone got me wrong and I feel I feel
sorry for this person and I know I
probably of course is very uncensored if
I could not laugh at jaffa cakes taking
someone's life absolutely of all the
things to die by this is absolutely
blown me away
I mean don't do it at home kids the only
reason we can report this is to say that
you lot do not shove as many Jaffa kicks
in your mother as you can they don't do
that shifting the tone little now in a
similar way to the way that they do in
this show just for context this is men
getting a [__] whilst trying to do
karaoke I think I'd be really good at
this really you've quite a numb are
quite like a singsong and I quite like a
con job I like the way I've never had a
woman looking at me so intently just why
would you do this I don't know but Japan
is so [__] modern it what's the why
why do that like what's the need for him
to do that I suppose it's their version
of sort of love island and it does not
mean he just does it the way thing is
he's not even looking at her what this
man is looking at has a studio full of
cameras and men operating them but and
probably I would imagine the words on
yeah and his mother I suppose
make me proud make me hold on there hold
on dog don't blow your Lord look at
mummy you you make you last longer
billionaire Diamond trader 65 dies
during penis enlargement surgery dying
because having a small dick he's Trump
the Jafar key in many respects a
statement from the diamond firm said
farewell to a visionary businessman it
is with great sadness that we confirm
that our founder has passed away a
friend of mr. Leonardo who's who wish to
remain anonymous say I love how it is
just want to be a touch of the stigma of
small dick ism although I'm gonna make
it out cording there was friends the
only time he forgot about his lack of
height was when he was asked accountant
to read his bank statement something
which he did multiple times City he used
to read bring up was a common to read
his bank statement owned the most
expensive penthouse in Monaco with more
than 30 million pound as well as a house
in a plush la suburb of ballet but now
all of that doesn't matter because he
died having a small penis operated on it
might have been a perfectly good 9
inches and he thought [__] it were going
for 19 yeah I mean that would be like
yeah I think we all know it's bollocks
he wasn't happy with his lot in life in
many ways and he thought no I want the
full package doesn't have any package
now now we ended up in the coffin he
looks like an Argentinian Ric Flair
ironically his fear of everyone finally
oh he had a small penis has now ended up
in him losing his life do all that means
just hear that [__] outlets never play a
small penis not be whatever you got
don't let your fear or new on your fear
if I was him nor genuine my favorite
life would be and you want to see my
diamond - no but it would have seen my
24 carat if a woman looks at you and
goes that's a bit of a letdown assume
collection of diamonds because they're
massive that makes up for it I don't
think it does I think you know the fact
that she hasn't orgasms probably is you
know annoying someone's taken the words
that Alex Jones says in his runs and
turn it into a song
[Music]
if use of the word literal is amazing
[__] flavor that was [__] they did
well with that they did very well they
managed to yeah it just shows how crazy
he is we take his comments out of
context Alex Jones is a sad sad man our
good friend the blue van man and his
vegan cheese as you can see I move
myself into the garage and I am trying
to see if I can get a better lighting
that's not a real good fluorescent tube
some kind of high-powered sports car
gone by the house there wobble it away
he's such a guarantee laughs this lug
he's just got such a great personality I
really want to meet him and what I want
is a barbecue you wanted to rate your
food if you cook them
absolutely but blue van man would love a
good barbecue
that's a nice lump of cheese you can see
all the Calipari knows I'm the onion and
stuff in there for the visually impaired
you can see that what I've just said for
the visually impaired you can see what
I've just said so I'm gonna bite into it
bear where they tell you the same family
they all got my DNA apart from the wife
and she's got a bit of my DNA so there
we go
welfare please Wow I suppose that was
vegan as well was it that's a big bite
of cheese austega he's born for it I
love it look at the eyes working here we
go he's downloading the deer are using
this tongue
I've got a little kick in it that really
is strong flavors wise I don't mean it's
strong and it tastes horrible it's
really really nice my god those guys
doing views are 15,000 27,000 limited
edition skittles 30 years I can't work
out how he would describe what's
happening to his friends so he goes
thing he goes yeah Steve yeah what
you've been what you didn't have a sweet
a YouTube channel sort of blown up
recently Steve what's the YouTube show
we just get a bit food Steven widget we
just stick in our gobs and we talk about
and people watch that oh yeah people
lots of people well 28,000 soaps now
what what a sub I said like some of that
BDSM oh no no no none of that [__] yeah
does the wife know about this some
semi-famous in the in the lesser area
Midlands viral I'm yeah I'm East
Midlands viral did Steve smoke a joint
before by popular request is on key
Steve it's not honky a few of you out
there seem to think it's hunky sleek no
it's nice funky Steve I know it's a bit
of an American word I don't know where
he's got this phone cuz only recently
mainly behind your backs
sassy together I love it I want to see
me like I've got the UH that's the chili
con carne folks that don't look too back
there's a nice little pop microwave is
you're supposed a thank you very much
okay or honk Easley there very much
you know there are mommy of like an old
1960s and 70s
double act that we're up on stage I'll
just hand you that Jess teeth well thank
you very much my friends into what they
know on them yeah and I love that I'll
let you hold it and then you can guide
it into your own mouth for the visually
impaired
yes for the visually impaired
sufficiently impaired it's got in it
he's visually impaired sorry sorry no no
that's fair because it was a genuineness
I didn't realize that I'd rather able
not meet hey god no wonder he keeps
mentioning the visually impaired easily
impaired yeah I didn't mean to be
I mean to be fair Steve could be
visually impaired unstoned we don't know
what I would say is ya wanna get stoned
in your blind you should be a lot to do
what the [__] you want yeah free world
although drugs I'm waiting for the kick
I'm waiting for the chili to Giggy I'd
love it if Steve just like silently the
whole buh-buh-buh leaving none nothing
goes no do we have another pot I love
what a brave youtuber blue van man and
funky Steve is and argh
they're not afraid of silence you've got
to be like that when you're in people's
company yeah I I'm like literally me and
you can chill not seen though yeah an
old problem you can tell what a lovely
relationship these two are because you
know they just sit together over
bromance and yeah and I fully back that
well if you've enjoyed today's episode
of true news and new buffs then you
might want to try our second sponsor of
the episode calm yeah I mean I use it on
a weekly basis I'm not someone who
particularly worries with stress right
now but I mean everyone gets a little
bit stressed at some point really help
me deal with it at some point it's sort
of a stress a worldwide thing it's not
just some people they get stressed
everyone suffers with it at some point
and I sort of used calm to deal with
that I prefer that listening to sort of
like the nature sounds and join me to
play one or two of those I mean yeah
they are quite good you do feel that
open I love the picture
this one's one of my favorites just a
late side remains we've diving yeah we
need less okay sorry my bad so if you do
want to check that out that is also in
the description below you get a discount
when you use our link so it's calm calm
slush Geordie Ally say that URL it's
calm calm forward slash journey that CA
LM calm /o Jordi good okay wow you
really thought about that a lot around
25% off the premiums is really impaired
yep you've heard it yeah that's good I
genuinely use it and Brian benefits from
that as well as one of my teammates is
very much and if you've enjoyed the show
don't forget to hit the like button
we're on Spotify iTunes all that good
[__] check us out everywhere and just
just keep praising us in the comments I
do love those nice ones you do you
really love hearting those yeah really
good but also because it's nice because
usually I block about five people assure
ya from their little [__] comments I
will be honest I think you do with more
of the Karma I think it would really
help you enjoyed it yeah but yeah thanks
for coming really appreciate it love
everyone who watches the show I love you
all that's nuts a lie I don't know any
of yous but I like you that I like this
right I saw it loved it like in the
audience yeah I appreciate you I don't
love you but thanks see you next week
Cheers
is gone sir he's gone literally clicked
off